los niños están siendo blanco en el
conflicto yihadista que perdura en el
norte de mozambique menores de hasta 11
años han sido decapitados en la
provincia de cabo delgado a manos de la
filial local del autodenominado estado
islámico según denuncia a la
organización save the children
elsa una madre de 28 años vio cómo
asesinaban a su hijo philip de 12 esa
noche nuestro pueblo fue atacado y se
quemaron casas cuando todo empezó estaba
en casa con mis cuatro hijos intentamos
escapar al bosque pero se llevaron a mi
hijo mayor y lo decapitaron no pudimos
hacer nada porque también nos matarían a
nosotros al menos 670 mil personas están
ahora desplazadas dentro del país debido
a conflicto en la región norteña una
situación que se ha intensificado
dramáticamente en el último año las
cifras son casi siete veces mayores con
la escalada de ataques a las aldeas la
mayoría de desplazados huyen a pemba
capital de la provincia en busca de
refugios otros viven en lugares
temporales pero el hambre está llevando
a muchos mozambiqueños a arriesgar sus
vidas emprendiendo la travesía de vuelta
a sus antiguas aldeas para recolectar
alimentos
y no nos apetece estar aquí
y la pueden poner cubiertas en las casas
pueden traer transportes trenes y
aviones pueden traer todo
lo que queremos es estar en nuestra casa
la tierra donde nacimos y el conflicto
yihadista comenzó en octubre de 2017 en
cabo delgado hogar de la insurgencia
desde entonces la violencia e
inseguridad no ha parado de crecer en
una región estratégica por su riqueza de
piedras preciosas y gas natural pero
donde más de 13 millones de personas
necesitan ayuda alimentaria y más de
950.000 se enfrentan a una hambruna
severa según naciones unidas